kneel before your queen I didn't think
so not possible darling you have no idea
what it's possible that was as ephraim
thor ragnarok the latest installment in
Marvel's comic book franchise stars
Crips Chris Hemsworth as Thor and it
hits theaters next weekend it is the
unofficial kickoff to Hollywood's
holiday movie season and here with a
look at what's to come is Eric Davis
managing editor of fandango.com Eric
good morning good morning to you all
right so there's a big superhero
showdown looming DC Comics Marvel Comics
let's talk first about I believe it's
Marvel's and entry Thor Ragnar yes and
that was emo Cate Blanchet by the way
attaching Thor's hammer she's fantastic
as the villain help and she always wore
Ragnarok yeah this is probably better
than the first two I would say much
sillier than the first two movies really
great superhero parody at times the
newcomers to this film are what really
sets it apart Cate Blanchet Tessa
Thompson Valkyrie really good in it also
Jeff Goldblum is a treasure in this film
Jeff Koch will make the treasure in a
lot of films Marvel should figure out a
way to keep Jeff Goldblum in the
franchise he's a fantastic so then two
weeks later Justice League opens Batman
Superman Wonder Woman Aquaman and the
flash yes I know grown men and women
who've been waiting their entire lives
to see a live-action Justice League
movie you know all these heroes coming
together is the big cell for me it's
Wonder Woman you know gal gadot's Wonder
Woman it has such an immense cultural
impact on the world
since patty Jenkins film came out over
the summer and so for me I think just
her presence in this movie is going to
elevate it exponentially I'm really
looking forward to it the action looks
action-packed so I'm excited I mean it
became a rallying cry for it'll be
really and we just did a survey on
Halloween costumes Wonder Woman the most
popular female Halloween costume and
costume okay Eric the most anticipated
movie of the season is Star Wars the
last Jedi yes what can you tell us my
friend well if this is a follow up to
Star Wars The Force awakens so we're
picking up with Ray and
fanon kylo ren's on these new characters
that we met Luke Skywalker is a big
presence in this film kind of looking
villainous mmm so I don't know you know
I talked to director Rian Johnson he
compared it to Empire Strikes Back
Empire Strikes Back
also Return of the Jedi and we can see
that a little bit in the pores the pores
like the Ewoks the pores have taken over
the Internet it was like she walks but I
see that's the difference between Gary
this is this is carrie fisher's laughs I
don't yeah and so we don't know exactly
how big her role in the movie is gonna
be the trailer alludes to the fact that
kylo Ren Mei may kill Princess Leia or
general Leia so we don't know we'll see
the trailer kind of finagles around a
bit but we hope that she has a major
presence in this movie I know a lot of
fans are looking forward to I am excited
for this one okay but there's also some
great fare coming out on Christmas
Bantam thread yes that made news Daniel
day-lewis is saying it's his last film I
believe I was directed by Paul Thomas
Anderson what do we know about this well
yeah Daniel day-lewis plays a dressmaker
at the center of 50s fashion London who
meets a woman and falls in love and of
course love completely ruins him like it
does to most of us but ya know it's he's
teaming with Paul Thomas Anderson the
last time these two met up where there
will be blood which is a really powerful
film and Daniel day-lewis I don't know
if this is his laser this is the kind of
guy that can go become a carpenter for
ten years right jay-z retired yeah
exactly so but yeah really looking
forward to it and keep an eye on the
Oscar nominations for him we have a time
about for about two more I'm gonna skip
ahead and go to a Tanya I Tanya it's
called
which is about the former figure skating
champion Tonya Harding I love this film
this is one of my favorite movies
interesting I mean I picked it it's
really great Margot Robbie plays Tonya
Harding and not that I would have cat no
you know what she does a fantastic job
this is a film I think that humanizes
Tonya Harding it redeems Tonya Harding I
think she's gonna have a lot of fans
championing her redeems her yes pay for
it no she did not but you know what it's
a dark comedy it's funny it's heartfelt
I think Allison Janney as Tonya
Harding's mom sells the movie